huh after I left the restaurant I sent
my secret diner to your restaurant
mm-hmm and this is what you saw Duncan
Duncan oh yeah if you see me how that's
okay sir sorry about that
no no but I wanna tell you we've got to
valid charge Thank You Simon
my undercover critic is having the trout
which some of my 30 diners left uneaten
for his Monica and also the peas Bullock
I thought the trout was slightly
undercooked I thought and the peas beans
can be done with another minute on the
block weighs about that but they were
underneath yeah there is no debate
mother damn it's about taste isn't it uh
excuse me
you're now gonna undermine my customer
she's got to take criticism seriously
that's cold
excuse me
this is the car sees God yes a bit cold
this dish dinners here she's a bit
taller than us and I'm afraid yeah
because it plates the plates of it okay
thank you
the cold he was bit like a headmaster
then if your children occasion if you're
working with families it's often very
hard to be objective about their
mistakes and their errors mum and dad as
always overprotective
as parents you're not drop them off to
school anymore the customers King
they're the ones parting with the 55
crater so the 10 courses the other ones
that want to boast of their friends on
the way back about coming to this
amazing amazing restaurant you have to
act a little bit more humble some
flowers
thank you it's the Pachanga the finale
in essence I'll say this is a this is a
very good strong trying to do excellent
things
and sometimes it's little bit misjudged
ab think about doing a tasting menu it
doesn't have ten dishes we just have six
dishes which are fabulous wish you had
ones you don't search from the monkey
once the place has the most amazing
potential yeah cuz my feedback is
crucial what you've got to do is just
listen when it's by the customers or by
asked about how you guys are feeling if
it's always been about our customers yes
no but I know I'm not taking so because
one could be better company a plane we
had to we had to have a plan how we
answer to the customer
Gordon say with three I treat them with
cotton water but perhaps is being a
father but yes we I'm gonna I'm going to
try to be a little bit tougher and put
my points of view across much in a match
tough away